today on judge Jessie judge Jessie turns
up the heat signed a piece of paper he
gave you the snake then you bring a
snake into the home applause I had not
been made aware that the snake would get
rid of his skin and then the sprinklers
came down with the snakeskin ruined my
carpet what what set off the sprinklers
unrelated popcorn fire your honor judge
Jessie as a police officer he defended
the streets as a trial lawyer objection
he fought for the truth as a black belt
he mastered discipline as a carpenter he
learned the value of craftsmanship as
the surgeon he mastered a cool head as a
crack ho he learned to go days without
sleep and as an announcer he does the
voiceover on this show coming up on
judge just a mr. Simmons before you
speak I know from experience that the
police have completely mishandled her
case and there's legal precedent for you
to win and any good defense attorney
would have told you that I also know
that obviously the place where you hurt
your back wasn't structurally up to code
mr. Oyama and furthermore as a sensei
you should know a man of his skill set
cannot do a Mike yaki you should know
that obviously I can tell by looking at
your alignment that you've herniated a
disc
someplace in your l4 or l5 I'm finding
for the plaintiff not $2,500 $2,700 mr.
Oyama thank you your honor you're quite
welcome
yeah yes dusty kind of second Nick
you